[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Nick Gillespie for recent TV do
you ever wonder what happens when a
celebrity plays a celebrity
well you get the new epic film where a
Lister Benicio del Toro plays a Lister
Ernesto Guevara the union of the two
supernovas was so intense that Khan the
glitziest Film Festival of them all had
little choice but to honor del Toro with
the Award for Best Actor Benicio del
Toro
the man Deltora depicted shot to a level
of stardom that few a-listers reach the
one-word name before there was Oprah
bono or Madonna
there was Jay chase the celebrity that
celebrities adore that's him on Johnny
Depp's neck and che is just about all
Gisele Bundchen is where Jay burst onto
the scene a half-century ago as an
idealistic revolutionary who helped
found communist Cuba today his
rebellious images used to sell countless
products beer flasks belt buckles
lighters fast-food diva would eat with
the best known shape product is the
t-shirt the chase shirts are so popular
that you can buy a t-shirt with the
famous t-shirt on it go to bust any kind
of protest and you're bound to see check
and from hip hop to rock to pop
musicians really dig che but is this a
case of unrequited love he hate artists
so how is possible that artists still to
date supported the image of Che Guevara
poquito de Rivera met J once and recalls
how hostile he was to D Rivera's dream
of becoming a musician chair was an
inspiration for me because ever since I
thought I had to get out of this island
as soon as I can
because I am in the wrong place at the
wrong time mister poquito B Riviera D
Rivera did escape Cuba and so far he's
won nine Grammy Awards playing the kind
of music che tried to silence as well as
jazz was what they called imperialist
music in the sixties and seventies
foreigner the culture was was Vito there
while Americans were fainting over the
Beatles D Rivera says Cuban fans
resorted to slipping the Fab Four's
records into album covers of government
approved performers we got they don't
want to be seen in the street with the
with the cover of The Beatles or old
Santana or any rockin roller so maybe
you can see why do you Rivera gets
annoyed at stuff like this at the 2005
Academy Awards Carlos Santana and
Antonio Banderas performed a song from
The Motorcycle Diaries the film that won
rave reviews for its tender depiction of
a young Che Guevara D Rivera called
Santana's performance
I mean sold to those young people that
have to hide your little piece because
your music was forbidden to Cuba the
symbol of rebellion actually enforce
conformity
[Music]
so if protesters tried this in Cuba she
wouldn't be marching with them his men
would be imprisoning them and perhaps
murdering them and the order of
execution of many people with no no no
trial she also served as Castro's chief
executioner presiding over the infamous
la cabaña prison he'd say the Bethenny
you first kill him and then you judge
him
that is very scary you know that's why
he was called El Camino like a manga the
butcher of like iron fortress so maybe
it's not such a great idea to wiggle
your toddler into a onesie with the
butcher of La cabanas mug on it
che is so iconic but few recognized
these faces just some of the many
victims of che and his firing squad
but when Deltora dedicated his award to
che himself the audience cheered pita
Guevara I look yes give it a few she
gave up years ago do Rivera sent a
letter to Benicio del Toro when she
explained who the real che was
[Music]
he also wrote an open letter to Santana
after his Oscar performance in which the
musician were a che shirt underneath
across that is like entering a synagogue
with a swastika on you in you on your
chest that doesn't make any sense just
the sight of a swastika fills us with
dread and for good reason
Adolf Hitler was one of the world's most
notorious mass murderers that's why the
British tabloids unloaded on Prince
Harry when he wore Nazi uniform to a
costume party but when the Prince hits
the town with a chase shirt it's just an
opportunity to make a cute pun Ave Anna
laughs get it ha Mike were rightly
horrified by fascist murderers why
aren't we also horrified by communist
killers certainly chase body-count isn't
anywhere near Hitler's but what about
someone che idolized someone who he
might have liked to wear on his chest
che Castro all the communist regimes
idolize only one thing that mal
personified violence
communist dictator Mao Zedong ruled
China when Kai Chen was growing up there
Chen played professional basketball in
China but his was far from the celebrity
life of an NBA star you have no right to
talk and you have no right to think as
he did for all Chinese Mao monitor
Chen's every move word and thought they
effectively eliminated you ability to
question anything questioning my
authority was especially dangerous if
you start questioning you endanger not
just yourself and your own family Chen's
relatives were kidnapped and forced into
labour camps people were hauled off and
killed all around him and mouths
iron-fisted economic policies created a
massive famine that killed 20 million
peasants people start eating each other
eating kids parents can even stand
eating their own kids the exchange their
kids with their neighbours calculating
communism death toll is a difficult task
but one taken on by the black book of
communism the books authors themselves
former communists estimate that Mao is
responsible for the deaths of 65 million
people that's vastly more than even
Hitler's body camera Mao is a murder a
biggest mass murder in human history
certainly no one would use the image of
the biggest mass murderer in human
history to move merchandise then again
maybe Mao is the new check you can buy
Mao watches commuter mugs caps and
t-shirts you can go all-out Kitsch and
tell the world that Mao is your homeboy
just a couple miles from Chen's Los
Angeles home he encounters a store
selling Mao shirts and a few doors down
there's a restaurant named after mam if
there's a emblem in there with swastika
you know how people are going to react
can you imagine a restaurant called
Hitler's kitchen vendor selling Hitler
mugs or t-shirts posting that Hitler
your homeboy what I see is is that I see
tears I say blood
neither Chen nor D Rivera understands
why communist killers are considered
chic but each finds his own way to have
the last laugh
I sort of crossed the mouth face because
Jenner in this certificate when his
basketball team won the Chinese national
championship in 1975 he crossed out
mouths face but only after he came to
America
what would this tiny protest have gotten
him in Mao's China oh I wouldn't be
standing here standing here talking to
you sometimes he make me feel happy when
I see somebody with those teachers do
you Rivera relishes the irony that a
communist would turn into a commodity
his success have been in the in the area
of human activity that he hate the most
marketing Che Guevara is the king of
marketing I love it
[Music]